Karen Winfrey: Hi everybody. I'm Karen Winfrey
from the communications team. Glad to have
you all here and those VC-ing in, welcome
also. We have a really great storyteller and
political reporter here today;John Heilemann,
talking about the best seller "Game Change",
subtitled "Obama and the Clintons, McCain
and Palin, and the Race of a Lifetime", and
I assume all of you are listening in because
you felt the same way. It was - it felt like
the race of a lifetime and it was only a year
ago, a little more, that things came to one
kind of fruition. John, wrote the book with
Mark Halperin. John is here today, on his
own. He's a longtime business and political
reporter for, uh a lot of well known publications
like, "The Economist" and "Wired", "The New
Yorker"; and now he is the national political
correspondent for "New York Magazine". This
book, "Game Change", (and there are copies
in the back here in the Mountain View), um
has been the number one - it was number one,
number one on the New York Times Bestseller
List for seven weeks which is very good for
a political book of this sort. And uh John
has been busy touring and Mark too, and uh
going over a lot of the fresh ground that
the two of them came up with to tell this
incredible story. So, John's going to talk
and then there will be a little time for question
and book signing at the end, and we'll end
at noon. So John - [applause]
John Heilemann: Thank you, Karen. That was
a very loud applause for a very small group
[laughs from audience] The enthusiasm is always
very high. Thank you for having me come here
back to one of the many hums in my professional
life. I spent four years in Silicon Valley
from 1998 to 2002, writing about people whose
degree of ego and vanity and hubris and neediness
is almost as great as those of Presidential
candidates I'm speaking of, high-tech CEO's.
[laughs from audience] Karen is right. The
subtitle of our book was not a mistake. A
large part of why Mark and I decided to write
the book was because though we'd been covering
presidential politics for 20 years, off and
on; my case, full straight through, and in
Mark's case, we thought that this campaign
was pretty extraordinary, and in fact, there
had been a general view about campaign books
which is that it was sort of a dead genre,
that people um-especially in an age of 24/7
news and the blogosphere and cable television,
that everyone knew everything there was to
now about any campaign in real time, and why
on earth would anybody want to read a book
about campaigns and support the past year
after it was over. We thought that this campaign
was different and we almost thought that there
were some mistakes in that analysis of the
news cycle. I'll talk about both of those
real quick. The first was that, you know,
as I say, Mark and I have covered Presidential
politics for a long time and we had never
seen a race quite like this one. We thought
it was the best race we'd ever covered and
would possibly ever cover. Every great story
has a couple of things in common and two features,
one of which is great characters and the other
is a big plot; and in the case of the 2008
campaign, we had both of those things in abundance
and I think part of the reason that the book
has done well, to the extent that it's done
well, is because people are in fact still
incredibly interested in all these people.
They are not interesting for politics, like
John Kerry or Dick Lugar, but they are interesting,
interesting people who could be on the cover
of "People" magazine or Oprah as easily as
they could be on the cover of "Professional
Quarterly". The Obamas, the Clintons, Sarah
Palin, of course, John McCain; these people
continue to be big players on the national
stage. People continue to pay a lot of attention
to them and want to know who they are, what
they're about, and what they're doing. So,
that was a big factor. We thought those characters
would be still interesting a year after the
campaign and it turns out they are. Another
factor of course was the plot which was part
of the reason
why we called the book "Game Change". There
were a lot of game changing moments, or potentially
game changing moments in 2008. It was a wild
ride by every standard and we thought that
would also help us and I think again to the
extent the book has been a success, the characters
and the plot are part of the reason why. We
also thought that the analysis of the fact
that the news cycle was so constant and that
there was so much coverage. In fact, this
race, you know, was certainly the most covered
and arguably the most over-covered race in
history, that that in fact opened a door for
us rather then closing one-and by that I mean,
you know, we had covered the race as closely
as any one and we'd read all this coverage.
And the fact was that the way that that news
cycle now works, every reporter is now a wiser
sort of reporter effectively. You are now
having not just do a story every day but do
multiple versions of the story on the web.
That creates enormous advantages in terms
of how fast we get the information, it also
creates real strains for reporters who are
not having the kind of time that they once
did to go back and really excavate what happened
as things occurred. So you have events that
take place, whether it's Barack Obama winning
the Iowa caucuses, or John McCain putting
Sarah Palin on the ticket. People are fascinated
and obsessed with those topics for a few moments
and reporters really fixate on them for 48
hours and then the circus moves on and they
have to move on with it. And so big questions;
by big questions, I don't mean big philosophical
questions. I mean, just fundamental questions
that I think not only political insiders want
to know the answers to, but many people who
were watching this race and talking about
it around watercoolers and kitchen tables
would ask themselves all the time. Mark and
I had those same questions and we didn't think
there were really satisfactory answers to
them at all the covers that we'd seen. And
again when I say big questions and fundamental
questions I mean things like, "How did Barack
Obama actually decide to run for President?",
"How has a guy who'd only been in the United
States Senate for about two years, who had
a very thin resume by any stretch, had a last
name that sounded like Osama and a middle
name that was Hussein, get it into his head
that he could be the first African American
President?", convince himself. He's not a
guy who is prone to flights of fancy, be very
cautious in a lot of respects, how did he
get to the point where he thought he could
beat Hillary Clinton? Who was by every stretch
of the imagination, the odds on favorite and
was seen as being the candidate who was going
to run away with the Democratic race. That
question, to my mind, had never been answered
and we thought that that was a rather important
question.You know, what was the relationship
between Bill and Hillary Clinton in the course
of her campaign? Many people had a lot of
speculative theories about whether President
Clinton had been running her campaign secretly,
whether he actually wanted her to win or was
trying to, in some way, sabotage her. Some
of these theories were crazy, some of them
were not less crazy, but again I couldn't.
I have even covered the Clintons. Mark and
I both have known both Clintons since 1991
or 1992 and having covered them for a long
time, I couldn't give you a good answer to
that question; what role did the President
really play in the campaign? And then of course,
the biggest mystery of all for a lot of people,
which was how did Sarah Palin actually get
on the Republican ticket? A question, again,
which people obsessed over for 48 hours and
walked away from. So we thought that in fact
if we took the time, which entailed a certain
risk, if we took the time and went back and
did a lot of interviews and did voluminous
interviews, not only great in number but also
great in the amount of time and effort that
we'd spent in doing them. We did - we talked
to over 200 people for the book, we did more
then 300 interviews and those were not follow-up
interviews but were the main interviews we
did. We did almost all in person and many
of them, virtually all of them, ran at least
an hour or an hour and a half, and many of
them ran five, six, seven hours and they were
like conducting oral histories. We had the
advantage of knowing virtually everybody who
we were writing about in the book, from the
candidates, to the most junior staffers who
worked for them, and have known them for a
long time. Having relationships with them
where we could sit down with them in a kind
of considerate way and explain what we were
trying to do, how the material that we got
from them was going to be used, and there
was - because of the fact that we knew them
so well, they were inclined to trust us and
I think as they started to see the kind of
questions we were asking and the time we were
taking with the process, they became more
trusting and they had also experienced this
race in the same way we had. It was kind of
an extraordinary thing; whether they had won
or lost, or worked for a winner or worked
for a loser, they recognized that this was
an event unlike most of the things they'd
ever done in politics before and they became
very much invested in the spirit of the project
that there was a reason to try and get this
campaign down and to do it in the way that
we were trying to do it and I think that also
goes to one of things about the book that's
a little different. The thing that I think
we were a little relentless about it without
trying to do this book, was not to write about
strategy and not to write about tactics, and
not write posters, and not to write about
consultants, but to try to write really about
these characters and about the candidates
and their spouses, and how going through this
process, which is some combination of meat
grinder and a flash incinerator, how that
process changed them, how they dealt with
it, how their strengths and weaknesses as
human beings manifested in the course of the
campaign and how it affected the outcome because
we both believe that it really did. In this
campaign in particular and in the Democratic
nomination fight, even more particular. The
differences of policy were minimal between
the candidates. Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama were not competing really on the basis
of big differences in terms of how they would
govern the country, they were campaigning
largely on the differences of visions, on
the differences of temperament, and style,
and character. And we felt that one of things
that were really missing in the lot of coverage
was a really intimate picture of what this
process was like in the early 21st century
and how these people went through it. And
that's what we set out to do. I think that
there's been, the book produced a fair amount
of news but beyond the news nuggets in the
book and the things that got headlines that
helped sell the book for sure. You know I
think people who actually sit down and read
the book rather then reading the coverage
of the book, find in all of the portrayals
in the book of much more nuanced and careful
and certainly right up close, kind of a picture
of all these people then they've gotten in
a lot of the other coverage and some of that
reflects badly on the candidates, and some
of it reflects really well on the candidates
and I think all of them show in the book the
real mix that affects and afflicts, in some
ways, all politicians...between the high nobility
of their polling and a lot of the personal
qualities that sometimes trip them up. I will
try to do two things over the course of the
next half an hour, based kind of on experience
of having done a fair number of these talks
in the last couple of months. One is talk
just a little bit about the core of the book
which I say is the candidates and their spouses,
but in particular talk about a handful of
the relationships that are the dominant relationships
in the book and that again was a real focus
for us, trying to hum in on the relationships
among the candidates; both as rivals, as in
some cases, as collaborators or as allies,
and talk about some of the surprising things
that we learned in the course of reporting
the book. And then I'll try to talk a little
bit more specifically about Obama because
I think a lot of people have asked over and
over again what do we learn from the book
about where he is now. And the book is kind
of scrupulously non analytical in a way. Though
Mark and I both get paid to do a lot of political
analysis, we try to tell this very much as
a story, just a straight narrative. But there
are clearly things in the book that if you
read the book intelligently, as I know anybody
who works at Google would do, you find that
there are lessons in the book that tell you
things, things are exposed about Obama's character
that bear very definitely on his situation
today. Before I do either one of those things,
even though this group is small, I'm going
to ask - I like to always get a feel for my
audience before I punch into the substance
of the talks so I'd like to figure out where
we all are politically so I'm going to ask
you guys in 2008 who you voted for. If you
feel uncomfortable voting in front of other
people, close your eyes. [laughs from audience]
So, how many people in the audience here voted
for Barack Obama for President? How many people
voted for John McCain? Okay, so that's a typical
crowd for northern California [laughs from
audience] Usually I'm blessed by like one
or two people who put up their hands for McCain
and then I can say, you know, for Northern
California, that's a very relatively diverse
audience and offer up Secret Service protection
for you. [laughs from audience] But in this
case - umm, let me ask one other question.
On the Democratic side, how many people voted
in the Democratic California Primary? How
many people voted for Barack Obama? How many
people voted for Hillary Clinton? Wow. See
now you guys - now that's a relatively diverse
audience for Northern California too so a
big Obama crowd here so we'll talk a lot of
about Barack Obama. [laughs from audience]
I think the core relationship in the book
is between Obama and Hillary Clinton and one
of the great pleasures that we had in doing
the book, I mean, I have known Obama for 22
years, which I'll talk about a little bit
more later. As I said, Mark and I both know
the Clintons really well but nevertheless,
there were a lot of things that we didn't
really know and one of the things that we
didn't know, like most of the country, we
observed the Clinton-Obama fight very much
from the context of them as rivals and heated
rivals, very bitter rivals at some point during
the campaign and the conflict was the prism
through which we saw it. As we started to
go back, we found out about the relationship
that the two of them had before the campaign,
which was really surprising to us, how much
Hillary Clinton had been a huge fan of Barack
Obama's when he first ran for Senate in 2004
in Illinois. We talk about her being desperate
to go see him before his speech at the Democratic
Convention. She had heard about this kind
of incredible political performer in Chicago.
She was asked to go out and do a fundraiser
for him. She was stuck on an airport tarmac,
not able to get out,
insisting that she would go rather then not,
rather then giving up she wanted to go see
this guy and find out what all the fuss was
about. Coming back incredibly impressed, telling
all of her friends that she'd never seen a
political neophyte who had as much potential
as Obama saying, "There's a superstar in Chicago."
Hosting a series of fundraisers for him at
her home in Washington, then back to Chicago,
sending her husband out to do a fundraiser
for him also, very much the kind of candidate
the Clintons historically would have wanted
to support. A bright, progressive African
American candidate, well spoken; a guy who
they really felt a kinship to in a lot of
ways and were incredibly happy when he won
the race and when he first came to Washington,
Hillary Clinton made herself very much available
to Obama as someone who could be an advisor
to her. Obama entered the Senate in a kind
of unique way, right? I mean, he was not your
normal freshman Senator in a institution that
basically prized seniority. He arrived as
a global superstar because of the Convention
speech in Denver. He was already getting hundreds
of requests to speak every week the day that
he walked in the United States Senate and
was able to raise a huge amount of money for
brother Democratics. He'd spent a lot of his
campaign for Senate because by the time he
won the nomination in Illinois, it was clear
he was going to win the general election.
He spent a lot of that Fall raising money
for other Democratic senators, even though
he was not a Senator yet which I think is
actually unprecedented in the history of American
politics. He was, you know, an, unusual uh,
unusually bright star and he recognized that's
a problem, that in the Senate, which is a
very high band institution, that trying to
arrive, arriving with that kind of celebrity
around you, could actually hinderyour ability
to be effective and there was only one person
in the Senate who had ever done anything like
that that he could see and that was Hillary
Clinton who had arrived in the Senate in 2000
to 2001 with exactly the same kind of level
of celebrity, global celebrity and had to
navigate the same kind of treacherous to making
herself an accepted member of the body so
Obama went to see her very early and said,
"How do I succeed?" She gave him advice about
what he needed to do and he was very much
a loner in the Senate. He had totally attracted
to her, talked to her more frequently, would
go and pull her aside, she would pull him
aside on the Senate floor. They were, I would
say, a budding relationship of "mentor and
pupil" in a lot of ways. He gave her a photograph
of him and Michelle and his daughters which
she kept on her desk, kind of prominently
displayed, until the day she left the US Senate
and I think that had it not been for his decision,
which she considered ridiculous, to run against
her, they could have been the best of friends.
But unfortunately Barack Obama had other ideas
and that kind of drove the wedge between the
two of them. We talk in a lot of detail in
the book about why the Clintons were so affronted
by Obama's decision to run but without wasting
a lot of time, you know the story after that
in some ways, just how bitterly contested
the Democratic fight was but I think it's
really important to recognize what
the foundation was because for a lot of people
the fact that Barack Obama asked Hillary Clinton
to be his Secretary of State was a huge surprise,
given - certainly a surprise to her, it was
a surprise to everyone around her, it was
a surprise to most of the people around Obama.
He had decided very early. Like one of the
great qualities about Barack Obama is his
ability to shed our rancor when the moment
for rancor is finished and so literally on
the day after he finally locked up the Democratic
nomination in early June, his attitude was
all that's the past, you know? These are things
people say in political campaigns, I don't
care. She's really smart, she's really savvy,
I want her in my Administration and people
around him were like, you know, "Are you crazy?"
They would then ask the natural next question
which was, "Well, why not put her on the ticket?"
And his answer to them was, "Well, I don't
really think it could work with three Presidents
in the White House." [laughs from audience]
Which is a fair point. He was determined not
to put her on ticket but was determined to
have her in the Administration and spent most
of the Fall campaign thinking in the back
of his mind that she would either be Secretary
of State or Secretary of Defense. And many
of the people around Obama thought it was
a horrible idea, that she couldn't be trusted,
that she would have her own agenda, that her
husband would be a huge problem, but Obama's
attitude was, "I don't care about any of that
stuff; what I care about is the fact that
the economic crisis is going to take up most
of my first couple of years. I need someone
to run foreign policy who I don't have to
hand hold, who I can trust to be able to be
America's face in the world, and who is not
going to say stupid things all the time."
One the reasons why
Joe Biden wouldn't have been a good Secretary
of State [laughs from audience] (and I love
Joe Biden by the way), but his attitude was,
you know, this is serious and she's a serious
person and I want to do this and from the
very first day after the election, he was
intent on the notion of putting her in office
and there's a - at the end of the book, the
epilogue of the book is really the story of
the two of them and how she, Hillary, does
not want this job, is trying to do everything
she can to keep from taking it, is totally
exhausted, does not want to work for Obama,
has this huge campaign debt still hanging
over her that she knows if she takes the job
will be harder to repay. Wants to go back
and have something like a semblance of a normal
life. And the process by which Obama convinces
her which culminates in a pretty extraordinary
after midnight one on one telephone call where
the two of them sort of get real with each
other in a way as human beings that they had
never done before. Each admitting a certain
vulnerability, certain political vulnerabilities,
and human needs that was a kind of conversation
they'd never been able to have before. How
she ends up in that partnership, also with
the incredible support of her husband, who
on one level was still furious about Obama's
victory but on the other level really thought
his wife could be a great Secretary of State
and wanted her to have the job, didn't want
to be blamed for her not getting the job.
How all that came about is kind of incredible
and I think that, to this day, among - the
relationships that Barack Obama has among
his cabinet, the relationship with Hillary
Clinton is the strongest relationship he has
with anybody else in the cabinet. They have
worked together
incredibly well in the first year and I think
that being the only way you can explain that,
both her decision to go in and, the fact that
they in the end have worked together is so
well, goes to many qualities of character
that they both have but it also goes back
to those early days when they first met each
other and what their relationship might have
been had the Democratic nomination fight not
intervened. We kind of fancifully in the book
say that the relationship between Hillary
and Barack is a love story, right? Boy meets
girl, boy and girl fight for the Democratic
nomination, boy loses girl, boy gets girl
back again. [laughs from audience] But the
other two relationships I'll talk about a
little bit are the Edwardses because again,
many people are interested in the Edwardses,
much to our surprise in some sense. And then
a little bit about John McCain and Sarah Palin.
The Edwardses, I think, were a decision that
when we decided to write a chapter in the
book about John Edwards, not at all the center
of the book but we were going to devote a
little space to him. It was a little bit of
a risky decision in some sense because Edwards
had fallen most further short of the White
House of anybody that we wrote about.It was
not at all clear that anyone in 2010 would
still care about John Edwards who had been
off the national scene since the middle of
2008. We wrote about their relationship for
a couple of reasons. One was because Edwards
had really, in much of our minds, choose to
tell us otherwise, had been someone who could
have easily been President of the United States.
Had he won the Iowa caucuses where he came
in second. He could have been a very plausible
Democratic nominee and therefore President.
He'd also obviously been the Vice Presidential
candidate in 2004, someone who came very close
to occupying at least the old executive office
building. And as we did the reporting on Edwards,
I think probably no candidate shocked us more.
Not just in terms of his behavior, which of
course now is large public but just the gap
between public image and private reality.
Every politician there is a gap of some distance
and Edwards was as great as any politician
that we'd ever covered and thataccording to
the people around them, the greatest they'd
ever seen. And that gap also extended to a
large extent to Elizabeth Edwards. And so
the story of this couple and the ways in which
the things that - the qualities I mentioned
before talking about high tech CEO's, ego,
vanity, hubris, and neediness; these are qualities
that every Presidential candidate has to some
degree, but the successful ones keep them
in check. They become motivational and they're
managed. In Edwards's case, they became all
consuming, and took him over and drove him,
I think, quite literally crazy and I say that
sometimes and people say, "Well, really? That
seems a little harsh", and then I have to
say well, wait! Not the affair, because many
politicians have had affairs, both aspiring
Presidents and actually Presidents in the
Oval Office as we know but the behavior afterwards.
The fact that so many people around him, as
we report in the book, from junior staffers
to senior staffers and best friends, knew
or suspected what was going on, trying to
get him to stop, that he was in denial about
the risks of how this might ruin his personal
life and his public profile, his
potential to ever be a serious person in American
life again. The way - most dramatically, I
think, after - we report in the book, after
he was out of the race his out of wedlock
had been born, you know? And was walking or
gurgling in a crib somewhere with Rielle Hunter,
how Edwards at the point still believed that
he could be the Vice President to either Barack
Obama or Hillary Clinton and was negotiating
very hard to get on the ticket. After that,
negotiating very hard to become Attorney General.
The idea that someone who had lived this lie,
could ultimately be confirmed as the United
States Attorney General is just nuts. It's
a delusion on a grand scale and I think that
one of things, the portrait of the two of
them is very vivid in the book and harsh in
the sense that portraying someone's madness
quite that clearly is kind of inevitably harsh.
But, what's been most striking about the reaction
to this part of the book, and peoples' interest
in it is again just how resonate a figure
- how resonate a pair of figures these two
people remain for a lot of people in America.
We were both surprised, Mark and I, in December
of last year when the Wall Street Journal
ran a poll where they asked people who the
most disappointing figures of 2009, the most
disappointing public figure of 2009. Edwards
won that poll, and collected twice as many
votes as the second place finisher who was
Tiger Woods, in the middle of the Tiger Woods
Sex Scandal. And 2009 was not a year where
John Edwards was in news very much actually.
So, that actually said something about how
much people were still fixated on the Edwardses.
And I think after traveling around and talking
to people about this for some time, I think
I now understand a little better why it's
true and I think it goes to this pervasive
fear that a lot of people in the public have
about politicians which is that they're all
phony and we all have that sense, we know
that there's some play acting who aren't this
involved in politics and in Edwards's case,
he's like the worst nightmare of every person
who believes that politicians are fake in
some way. Someone who's represented himself
to be something totally other then who he
really turns out to be and I think it fuels
peoples' fear. It's like that nightmare scenario,
not just for people who gave money to him,
of whom there were many, of people who voted
for him but for all voters. They sensed that
- they see in him kind of, as I say, the
worst nightmare about what their fear is about
all politicians and I think that's part of
why he continues to be such a resonate figure
for so many people. The first story I said
was a love story, the second story is sort
of a wreck on a highway. The third story,
John McCain and Sarah Palin, we like to think
of as sort of "Stranger on a Train" [laughs
from audience] because the truth is that John
McCain didn't really know Sarah Palin when
he put her on the ticket and one of the things
that we try to do in the book was - we had
been told, like America had been told by the
McCain campaign, that when Sarah Palin was
put on the ticket that she had been on the
short list for Vice President for months and
that she had received as much scrutiny as
anybody else who they seriously considered
putting on the ticket. Rarely in politics
do people lie quite that boldly to reporters
and to the country. The book shows just how
last minute and half-hazard the decision to
put Sarah Palin on the ticket is...I won't
spend a vast amount of time on it except to
say that for most of the summer of 2008, John
McCain was going to try and do a game changing
pick for his Vice Presidential nominee. They
were convinced they needed to really change
the playing field in a profound way because
Obama's strengths, in terms of fundraising
and organization, were so great that there
was very little likelihood that McCain could
win if he ran a conventional campaign. So
his game changing idea for all that summer
was to pick Joe Lieberman, the former Democratic
Vice Presidential nominee under Al Gore. A
conventionally liberal Democrat on almost
all matters of social and domestic policy
but much more conservative on foreign policy
and security policy, for sure. But the notion
was they would run as a unity ticket and say
they would take a one turn pledge and serve
the country for four years and try to tackle
big problems in a bipartisan way. The problem
with that and McCain, it should be noted that
he just loves Joe Liberman. He's one of his
closest friends in the Senate, and he really
wanted to run with Liberman so all those reasons.
And then they realized that they couldn't
do it and that the Republican primary electorate,
the Republican Convention delegates wouldn't
accept a candidate that liberal. They heard
from a lot of people in the Conservative movement
that if they put Liberman on the ticket, he
might not make it through the Convention and
if he did make it through the Convention it
would spark such a civil war that it would
destroy McCain's convention and leave him
worse off then if he had picked a more conventional
candidate. So literally four nights, five
nights before his deadline, they looked at
the field and said, "You know, the
people who we've actually scrutinized, people
like Mitt Romney and Tim Pawlenty will not
help us win. We can't put Joe Liberman on
the ticket. What are we going to do?" And
at that point, the name Sarah Palin was placed
on the table. Now, that they had discovered
Sarah Palin a few weeks earlier when a Rick
Davis, John McCain's campaign manager, sat
down in front of his computer and thanks to
the good people over at YouTube, was able
to discover Sarah Palin by typing in the names
of all the female office holders, public in
office in the country. He came upon a video
of Sarah Palin on the "Charlie Rose" show,
and thought that she jumped off the screen
and she was exciting, and that put her in
contention. At the time that McCain, in this
last week before he had to make this choice
on a Friday morning...The amount of vetting
that she received was one Washington lawyer,
a junior lawyer, sitting in his office for
about 40 hours searching Google. Again, thank
you very much Google. [laughs from audience]
They looked through public record searches
and looking at newspaper clips. Now, if anybody
here knows anything about Presidential vetting
processes, this is not the way most Vice Presidential
candidates are vetted and certainly not the
way that Barack Obama's vetting team vetted
within an inch of their lives every single
person who they seriously considered for his
ticket. The McCain campaign did not ever send
anyone to Alaska. They did not speak to her
political enemies, they did not speak to her
political friends, they did not speak to her
husband or children. The 77 part questionnaire
that every other candidate filled out; some
of them like Mitt Romney took two months filling
it out, Sarah Palin did it in a half a day
and left a lot of the questions blank. She
arrived in Arizona on the night before she
was going to first have a serious conversation
with anybody, McCain staff and McCain, about
being on the ticket. Having not met any of
the senior advisors, many of them did not
know how to pronounce her name when she arrived
in Arizona. They didn't know if it was 'pal-in'
or 'pa-lin'. No one had ever had a conversation
with her and did not, even after McCain put
her on the ticket, no one had had a conversation
with her about what she knew about domestic
policy, about foreign policy, their assumption
was that she would know as much as the average
governor. That turned out to not be quite
true. And they, had a very clear picture that
she was very calm and very poised and very
charismatic, they did not really do enough
scrutiny to get to the point where they realized
that she had what we have mistily referred
to as "limited bandwidth". [laughs from audience]
She - on the night before she met McCain,
she had a conversation with his senior vetting
lawyer, an esteemed graveur from Washington
DC named A.B Culvahouse called the house,
interviewed all the other Vice Presidential
candidates in person for many hours. They
did not have time to do that so he found himself
doing a phone interview with Palin in the
middle of the night, hours before she was
going to go to McCain's ranch and meet McCain
and Culvahouse asked her if she had anything
to tell him and she said, "Well, I should
tell you my daughter is pregnant." That was
the first time they learned that Bristol Palin
was pregnant. Culvahouse took a deep breath
and said, "Is she planning to get married?"
And there was another long pause and he said,
"Is she planning to get married tomorrow?"
And Sarah Palin didn't think that was very
funny. But this gives you a picture just how
little they knew about this woman when they
put her on the ticket and I think the important
thing to know from that is, you know, someone
from the McCain campaign, Nicole Wallace,
one of his main communication advisors said
the other day in an interview that even if
you put Jesus Christ on the ticket, you'd
need to do a lot of preparation because no
matter who you are on the ticket, you will
come under relentless scrutiny and withering
attacks from the other side. In order to be
able to defend your candidate, it takes a
lot of time to know their record, to have
defenses mounted. The McCain campaign, by
being so half-hazard and so slip shot in the
way that they chose Sarah Palin, they did
not serve her well. She was not put in a position
where she could succeed, they put her in a
position where she was almost doomed to fail
and to a large extent, whatever you think
of Sarah Palin, the ultimate responsibility
for the problem goes back to John McCain and
the people around him who made, I think, a
terrible blunder by not doing the kind of
preparation that's required in these circumstances.
The rest of the McCain-Palin story is colorful
and I urge you to read the book because some
of the scenes in it are quite stunning and
I think if anybody here in this room is thinking
about voting for Sarah Palin in 2012, the
fact is that none of you are, not a single
one [laughs from audience] but if you are,
you'd want to read these - those portions
of the book so you get a sense of what she's
really like. I said I would talk about Obama.
For the next ten or fifteen minutes, I will.
I first met Barack Obama in
1988. We were both graduate students at Harvard
arriving there; him to Harvard Law School
and me at the Kennedy School of Government.
We struck up an immediate rapport. I was standing
on the steps of Langdell Library at the Law
School smoking a cigarette and holding a pack
of Marlboro Reds as I smoked and he walked
up and said, "Can I bum one of those?", and
I said, "Sure", and I gave it to him and I
said, "This man is going to be the first African
American President of the United States."
[laughs from audience] At least, that's how
I like to tell the story. [laughs from audience]
That was really the extent of our relationship
for those two years. He'd bum cigarettes from
me and I gave him cigarettes and now we share
a common addiction to Nicorette. But I have
watched Obama pretty carefully. I've reported
on him for a pretty long time. And he's an
extraordinary political talent in a lot of
respects but there are a lot of other things
to say about him beyond that so let me talk
about the things that to try and answer the
question, which I said earlier has been asked,
it gets asked constantly about the book;what
does it say about where Barack Obama is now?
I think there are a number of things that
you see in "Game Change" about Obama that
bear directly on today. And I'll start I guess
with his aversion to, or allergy to, the artifice
of politics. One of the stories in the book
that I think people again, with the benefit
of hindsight or the hindrance of hindsight
in some ways, don't remember is just what
a bad candidate he was in 2007. In a lot of
respects, the weak leak in the Obama campaign
in 2007 was Barack Obama. He was miserable
much of the time in those early days of the
campaign. His campaign was raising a ton of
money and there was a ton of enthusiasm about
him in
the country and he was formidable in those
respects that he was doing things that were
providing objective metrics that made him
look like a serious challenger and yet on
the stump he was almost repelled by the idea
of doing what the people wanted him to do
which was to give the 2004 Convention speech
over and over again, and on a number of occasions
he would complain to people around him, "You
know, everyone who wants to comes here wants
to leave the room in tears and I can't do
that five times a day. That's not the speech
I can give, it's not the speech I want to
give five times a day. It's not a reasonable
expectation." He missed his family enormously
and hated the press coverage of the campaign,
thought it was too 'horse racy', wasn't substantive
enough, hated more then anything the debates,
which he thought were a totally artificial
format. He was a kind of guy, a professorial,in
the sense that he was trying to get as much
information into every answer as possible
so literally in debate prep he would say,
"I have a minute for this response. How many
things can I get in?", you know? Which is
not the most effective means of political
communication. And if you remember those debates
in 2007, there were a lot of them, he was
really destroyed by Hillary Clinton, like
time and time again. Her greater experience
in this realm and her savvy about being able
to talk in a very sophisticated way about
policy but in a very clear way, she beat him
and he knew it. But debate after debate he
would go out and be very frustrated by the
fact thatthe format combined with Hillary's
mastery of the format, meant that he was losing
over and over again. And it got to the point
where in the summer of 2008, many of the people
who had urged him to run, the people who were
closest to him, started to wonder whether
it was a mistake and rather they had talked
him into something that he didn't really have
the heart for. We talk about it in the book,
you know, Obama's decision to run which is
a longer story but you know there is a moment
just as he's about to decide to go where he
has a conversation with David Axelrod where
Axelrod says, "Look, I've worked for Hillary
Clinton and I've worked for John Edwards and
I know what they will do to win. They know
where they are going to be three months from
now. Every hour of the day, they are scheduled
all the way out into the Fall. If they have
a 105 temperature, they'll look it up and
they'll put in a 15 hour day. I don't think
you're necessarily crazy enough to be President.
You don't want this bad enough. I mean, you
want to be President but you don't need to
be President and that could be a problem."
And Obama's attitude was, "Yeah, that's true
but I think I'd be a good President and I'm
really competitive and I think that my competitiveness
will come out, and I want to reject the notion
that you have to be borderline insane to run
for President of the United States. It's got
to be that we can elect sane people President
of the United States." A very radical stipulation
on his part [laughs from audience] but I think
by some point in 2007, he obviously turned
things around in the Fall but the year holds
a lesson, which is that, and I think we've
seen this in the course of 2009 which is Obama's,
as I said before, allergy to the artifice
of politics. His desire, a noble desire I
think, to have an adult conversation with
people, something that has worked for and
to his advantage in many settings, has been
a hindrance in way in this last year and I
think people expected Obama to be a much more
inspirational figure. And what has happened
of course in 2009 and into 2010 [coughs] excuse
me, has been that he's been caught in the
weeds and has seemed to people much more a
creature bogged down in the legislative process,
stuck in Washington, not out on the hustings,
not inspiring people in the way that he did
during the campaign and I think for
a lot of people that's led to some disappointment.
I think his attitude towards it is that this
is a serious time and I need to be serious
but that disjuncture, his kind of at times
strange aversion to wanting to be an inspirational
figure who is speaking with passion, and rather
speaking within a more rational, empirical
way has actually hurt him to some extent politically
over the course of the last year. Another
thing you see in "Game Change" is the way
that Obama deals with crises and there really
were two places in 2008 where Obama faced
something that looked like a crises. I am
going to put Reverend Wright aside for a moment
because it was very kind of a specific thing.
The big crises that he faced that were more
macro were in the Fall of 2007 and the Fall
of 2008. In the Fall of 2007, Hillary Clinton
was ahead by 35 points in the national polls.
Many of Obama's donors and a lot of national
Democrats saying, "You have to change course.
This is not working. You are going to lose,
where you wasted all this time and money.
You've wasted our time and money. What are
you doing here? You have to take her on, you
have to attack her, kneecap her. Take the
meat cleaver out and put it in her back."
In the Fall of 2008, when again, hindsight
blinds us to some of the difficult truths
of the 2008 campaign, there was a moment in
the Fall of 2008 when John McCain was ahead.
A week after Sarah Palin was put on the ticket,
before some of her weaknesses became clear,
before the financial crisis happened, Obama
was actually losing in the middle of September.
According to those national polls, McCain
was ahead by two or three points. At that
moment again, Democrats around the country
were freaking out, "You have to change course,
you have to destroy Sarah Palin, you have
to attack John McCain, you have to do the
following things." And Obama's attitude, which
was in fact exemplified by David Plouffe his
campaign manager, referred to those Democrats
who were complaining and panicking as "bedwetters".
Obama's attitude was, in both instances, was,
"We have a strategy, we have a plan. We are
going to stick to this. It was well thought
through, and we're not going to change because
of these momentary vagaries of our fortune."
In both those instances in the campaign, it
worked enormously to Obama's advantage. It
worked out really well. I think the question
today is whether they've learned that lesson
too well, whether they've overlearned that
lesson and one of the questions again, I think
it's an open question, his attitude has been
towards the crises or the difficulties he's
been facing for the last few months around
healthcare and other things has been exactly
the same as it was in the campaign. We have
a plan, we have a strategy, we've thought
this through, we are going to keep doing that,
and he's basically put his head down. You
know,[speaker stumbles] one of your board
members, John Doerr, often likes to say, "There's
a time when panic is the appropriate reaction."
And I don't know whether this time is that
time for Obama but there are many people who
would say that a more serious mid-course correction
is required then the one that he's so far
enacted and I think regardless of whether
healthcare passes, it's quite likely Democrats
are going to suffer pretty significant losses
in the House of Senate this Fall, and will
face Obama with a crisis that will be greater
then any political crisis he's ever faced
before. This is not a guy who has had a lot
of setbacks in his life politically. He's
had a very difficult, has had real challenges
to overcome as a child and it's in his biography
but as a politician has lost almost nothing
and Hillary Clinton use to often bemoan the
fact that the Democrats were about to nominate
someone who had never had a negative ad run
against him in his life which was actually
true until she did [laughs from audience]
in March of 2008 but he's not a guy like Bill
Clinton or like Ronald Reagan for that matter
whose political character has been shaped
by adversity, who lost big things, and had
to, in a resourceful way, pick himself back
up and move on and figure out how to make,
to find a way forward, how to improvise, and
make the best of a bad situation or make lemonade
out of lemons. I think, you know, Obama is
facing a moment where if healthcare fails,
the moment will be upon him now. If healthcare
does not fail, the moment will be upon him
in November and the question of whether he
decides to improvise or to change course in
a dramatic way or do what he's done and did
in 2008 which is put his head down and stick
to his plan, that will be a decisive moment
in shaping the
rest of the Presidency, I think. What are
my other Obama points? I'm going to look here.Right...
Let me talk about two other things that you
really see in the book that are things that
have, I think, are relevant to today. One
is the perception and I think this goes to
a lot of what some people feel they are frustrated
by with Obama. The perception of Obama coming
into Washington was that he was going to be
a great change agent and was going to fundamentally
change the culture and process of how Washington
worked. In addition to being a post partisan,
who would reach across the partisan island,
and would be able to usher us into an era
where the polarization of our politics was
less damaging to the public good. There was
also this notion that in many ways he would
sort of sweep in and clean out the ugly end
stables in Washington. I think one of the
most important things in the book in a lot
of ways is the misperception that it conveys
of Obama as an insurgent figure. I was not
actually very clear in what I was saying a
second ago. I think many people thought that
Obama was an insurgent figure. I think the
book shows the extent to which Obama was much
more at core,[inaudible], at his character
logical and cultural core, is a much more
establishment figure then many of the people
who were so enamored in thought. I don't say
that in a bad or critical way, it's just a
fact and I think the book, if there's a big
story in this book in terms of news and I
mean historically important, it's the stuff
that
we write in the book about the extent to which
the Democrat establishment, who everybody
thought were lined up behind Hillary Clinton
in 2006, were in fact quietly conspiring to
get Obama to run against her. They have various
reasons why they thought Hillary Clinton would
be a bad general election candidate and so
people like Harry Reid, the Senate Majority
Leader, extensively neutral in the race; Tom
Daschle, the former Senate Majority Leader;
even people who were publicly supportive of
Hillary Clinton, publicly endorsed like Chuck
Schumer, her colleague from the New York Senate,
were actually secretly going to Obama saying,
"Hillary Clinton is too polarizing to win.
She'll lose the election, she'll drag down
Democrats across the country. Her husband's
personal life could explode in his lap if
Republicans make an issue of the things that
Bill Clinton's doing in his private time.
In the Fall campaign, that could be a disaster.
We need an alternative." And they sought Obama
out. We refer to it in the book as "the conspiracy
of whispers" but he had dozens of Democratic
senators pulling him aside saying, "You need
to take the Clintons on." I think that was
influential, not the reason he ran, but it
gave him comfort that what was supposed to
be this iron wall of support behind Hillary
in the establishment that it wasn't really
true and that there was actually more of an
opening there then many people thought. But
I also think it reflects on what I was talking
about a second ago which is this is not a
guy, to the extent that people thought Hillary
Clinton was the establishment candidate, we
could argue that Obama was as much or more
the establishment candidate then Hillary was
and you could see that when the super delegates
finally started to tumble in Obama's direction.
They were supposed to be the firewall for
Hillary Clinton but they ended up in Obama's
camp and the seeds of that were in this period
of 2006 I just described but this is not a
guy with that kind of establishment backing.
That much appealed to the Democratic establishment.
This is not someone who arrives in Washington
like a revolutionary figure and tries to burn
the place down and so a lot of the, what has
seemed to be, a much more accommodationist
attitude towards Washington and trying to
get things down within the existing power
structure rather then replacing it or reforming
it or stripping it bare. I think that's all
very consistent with this story of how he
got there. The last thing I'll say is I'll
say that I think that Obama, when he ran for
President, my co-author often very wisely
says, "The Presidential candidates do exactly
what they need to do win and not an inch more,
not an iota more then what they need, exactly
the amount they need to get across the finish
line." And in Obama's case, I think in the
Democratic nomination fight, the main thing
Obama needed to be was not a Clinton and he
did that very well. In the general election,
he needed to not be George Bush or not anybody
who looked like or smelled like or sounded
like George Bush, or who could be caricatured
as sounding like a clone of George Bush. Both
those things were, this is a kind of 20,000
foot analysis, but I think it's fundamentally
true. What that meant was that Obama did not
have to do something that other Presidential
candidates have had to do and the two that
come to mind most strikingly are both Bill
Clinton and Ronald Reagan, who had very deep
and well articulated theories of the case.
By which I mean, they had not just policies
that they wanted to enact, and not just inspirational
rhetoric, but they had a view of where the
country was at a particular
moment in history, they had real ideologies.
They had a coherent way of getting together
their policies and their rhetoric and talking
about, in a narrative way, this is where the
country is, this is where we want to go, this
is what I believe the role of government is
at this moment, and here's how all this stuff
comes together in a coherent whole. Obama
didn't have to do that. He had some really
good policies and he obviously had incredibly
inspirational rhetoric. He promised a change
that I think he believed in, in terms of as
I said before being kind of post partisan,
but what you didn't have was that kind of
theory in the case in the middle that knitted
everything together and I think it's hurt
him enormously in the course of this first
year of it. I think there is enormous confusion
still in the country about who this guy is
and what his theory is, what his plan is,
and how the stuff that he's trying to get
done fits in with this bigger vision of America
where it is today and where he wants to take
it, and so you have this strange situation
now where much of the Democratic party is
dispirited with Obama in one way or another.
Much of the left thinks he's been much more
centrist and much more compromising and accommodationist
then they thought he would be and that they
think he should be. I think you have many
Democrats who are more conservative Democrats
or Democrats who you would call Centrist who
think Obama has been way too much of a big
government Liberal. And I think part of that
confusion owes to a very successful campaign
by Republicans to caricature him certainly
but it also owes to the fact that he's not
been sufficiently clear with people about
this thing that I keep referring to as the
theory of the case. And I think it again something
that Bill Clinton and Ronald Reagan had in
spades, something Obama has not had and I
do think that for the future political success
of his administration being able to be more
clear and more precise about what his vision
of governance is and where it fits into the
times we live in is something that's going
to be essential to him being as successful
a President as he could be, he could still
be despite all the difficulties that he's
faced over this first 14 months. With that,
I will halt; I'll stop[Laughs],and thank you
for coming and take any questions that anybody
has here. [applause]
>> Hi. I thought the book was really fascinating
and one of the most fascinating parts was
just the scenes between Hillary and say a
close group of people in her campaign. And
I'm wondering with your sources, why were
they so willing to be so honest and paint
the candidate in a bad light, whether it's
Hillary or Obama or John Edwards? And have
you heard from any of your sources regretting
being so honest, and uh in painting such a
negative picture of the candidates?
John Heilemann: Those are both good questions.
You know, I mentioned earlier that Mark and
I had been doing this for a long time so we
had relationships with a lot of people that
stretch back a long time and so that's the
opening salvo to that answer is that. We were
surprised often by how open people were. We
did not as a general matter or even in very
many specific cases have to go and pull teeth
out of people to get the information that
we got. We would sit down with people and
say, "Tell us about what happened", and the
stories sort of poured out. So I think in
some cases there were probably some people
who were frustrated with what they saw as
the failings in their candidates, if it was
a negative situation. And I think also that
the way this reporting works is it's through
the kind of accretion of small details and
so in a given meeting you would get - someone
who tell a story about how this meeting happened
and then you know, we would know an account
of that meeting would go to the other people
in the meeting and as you start to demonstrate
that you know something about what happened,
people are both - there's an interesting kind
of human instinct to want to add your "two
cents" to the story. So whether the correct
things that they thought that we had heard
in error, or just to add a small detail. So
we were relentless in terms of trying to talk
to, in any given meeting, trying to talk to
everybody who was there in the meeting probably
including from the candidates down to whoever
happened to be in the room with someone we
tried to talk to. In many cases in the book,
if there was meeting that we talked about,
we talked to everyone in the meeting. In many
cases we also had
contemporaneous notes that people took of
the meetings and in some cases we had recordings
of things that people had recorded in certain
situations. So uh, I think that people have
a natural desire to tell stories, and to testify
to their experience, and I also have a belief
that most people tend to be truthful rather
then lie, or at least to the best of their
memory. Memories are flawed, but people try
to tell
the truth and so when you have someone who's
decided they want to participate in doing
something they think will be important to
history and you sit them down and ask them
and show them that you're not trying - you're
not looking for a particular answer, you're
just trying to understand what happened; the
natural instincts of wanting to tell your
stories and wanting to be truthful I think
all sort of kick in, and people tend to do
that rather then trying to sugarcoat things.
Certainly the fact that we did most of these
interviews after the campaign was over, shortly
after the campaign was over; most of the stuff
we did was started immediately after election
day. We did some
interviewing in the summer of 2008. Remember,
we were trying to get people when memories
were still fresh. But clearly the fact that
the contest was over, and that we were writing
for a book that was not going to affect the
outcome had a huge impact there towards peoples'
candidness and the last question you asked;
we've heard from tons of people who we talked
to for the book. I said before we talked to,
we had more then 200 sources for the book.
We haven't heard from everybody but we've
heard from many people and every single thing
we've heard from everybody has been that they
felt they were treated fairly, that we were
very explicit with people about what we were
going to do with the material we were getting,
about what the ground rules were for our conversations
and people have come back in some cases and
said, "You know, that was a tough passage.
That was tough to read that portrait of my
boss but you got it right and you didn't screw
me." And so to this point at least, we're
pretty happy with the response we've gotten
from everybody involved in the book.
>> So what did the experience of putting the
book together after the fact teach you about
how you think political journalism and campaign
coverage could be done differently while it's
actually happening?
John Heilemann: Well, it's a really good question
and I don't know that I have a good answer
for it. I do think that it's not a secret
that this notion that the public, the public
image and the private reality of candidates
diverge to some extent, sometimes a lot, sometimes
a little. Uh and I think it's a salutary thing
for voters to keep and a salutary thing for
the press to keep in mind as they do this,
as they embark on whatever 'do this' is, in
the case of voters evaluate candidates to
decide who they're going to vote for and in
the case of journalists trying to cover them.
I don't know the forces that are at work in
shaping campaign coverage on a day to day
basis are so big that...by that I mean the
nonstop news cycle, the web in particular.
It's not clear to me how you turn back that
tide. It's a - the thing that I would like
to see that, I don't know - I have no idea
how one would engineer this but I think the
most regrettable thing that; and I think Mark
would agree with this; that we've seen in
the course of doing this for 20 years is that
it's really hard now for reporters to actually
get to know the people they cover. And it's
a combination of the time pressures on them
to produce and those time pressures meaning
that people who log their reporting by IM
or log their reporting by phone or log their
reporting by email, and don't actually spend
time, even with secondary sources; by secondary
sources, I mean not the candidates but even
the advisors around them. They don't really
have personal bonds with those people so they
have all these time pressures that keep them
from doing a lot of face to face reporting
and certainly keep them from doing like a
long and extensive interviewing. On the candidates
side, the imperative now - I mean, it's always
the imperative in every Presidential campaign
or every political campaign; you know, control
your public image is the paramount challenge,
right? And what people have learned, again
regrettably I think, is that there's a very
little upside to direct engagement with the
press. And so some people say, "Well, their
so good at image manipulation", and I don't
really take that point of view but it is true
that candidates and journalists very rarely
interact anymore. And so you can travel on
a candidates' camp, on a candidates campaign
plane for days without ever talking with the
candidate and if you do talk to the candidate,
he walks to the back of plane and does a gaggle
with all the reporters on the place for five
minutes and then goes back to the front. You
know, 20 years ago Mark and I - Mark got to
know Bill Clinton by traveling around with
him every day, you know. Riding on the backs
of buses and planes with him for months and
months and months, and there are candidates
that I can say that I've spent hours and hours
and hours with, and nobody gets to do that
really anymore unless you have the privileged
status of having known that person before
and maybe you're
working on a big magazine profile. But this
huge wall between reporters and candidates
is a huge problem, and it's a problem in both
directions, I think. It's a problem in the
sense that the public doesn't get as clear
a picture of who these people really are,
and I actually think it's disadvantageous
to the candidates in some ways also because
you know there was a time, and I hate to sound
like an old man, but you know if you knew
a candidate well and you had spent a lot of
time with them and they said something stupid,
you were in some cases like, "Well, he didn't
mean that", you know? I know he didn't mean
that, I've heard him give this answer six
times and that was a slip of the tongue. That
was not a reflection of what he really thinks
and feels about something, and so I'm not
going to write that to embarrass him. It's
just not who this person really is. I don't
mean something horrendously inflammatory,
I mean like some dumb thing where he said
the word 'not' when he meant to say'would',
you know? Nobody does that anymore. And now
the game is a gotcha game largely and if a
candidate stumbles and says something in error,
it becomes a huge deal where everybody who's
writing about it focuses on the thing and
then it
becomes - and they get misinterpreted more
then fairly interpreted. All that's a way
of me dancing around the fact that I don't
really know how to fix that problem but it
seems to me that it would be advantageous
to everybody involved in the process if we
could in some way get back to a situation
where candidates and journalists actually
got to know each other and there was a spirit
of greater trust that didn't take away of
their appropriately adversarial role that
the press should play in the system, but got
you closer to something that vaguely resembled
truth; that would be a good thing.
>> Thanks
>> One more.
>> Hi. I bought a copy of your book but my
daughter took it away to college so I gotta
get another one.
John Heilemann: I'll take yours too though
[laughs]
>> Okay. I wanted to correct one other thing
you said. You said nobody in here was going
to vote for Sarah Palin and I'm actually registering
as a Republican in 2012 to vote for her in
the primary. There's a bumper sticker out
here that you probably haven't seen in northern
California.
John Heilemann: Really? Didn't you just say
you voted for Barack Obama before?
>> I did.
John Heilemann: And now you're going to vote
for Sarah Palin?
>> In the primary. [laughs from audience]
John Heilemann: Ah. Strategic voting.
>> The bumper sticker says, "Palin in 2012:
We'd love to kick your ass again." [laughs
from audience] My question to you is more
about -
John Heilemann: That's funny. You got the
kind of like Sarah Palin is going to be in
this.
>> I don't think she's really going to have
a chance in the primary but in the 2008 election,
I wonder if you could just talk for a few
minutes about what happened in New Hampshire.
All of the polls ahead of that primary had
shown that Barack Obama was going to win.
He had come out of the Iowa caucuses with
a gold halo and nobody expected Hillary Clinton
to take that particular primary. What do you
think actually happened there?
John Heilemann: That's a good question and
I think I know the answer; that's what makes
it an even better question. Where to start?
Mark Penn, Hillary Clinton's Chief Strategist,
had a theory which was that a lot of - the
Clintons obviously have a strong connection
to the state of New Hampshire that Obama never
had. Obama had done
a lot of work in Iowa, the Clintons had never
had a history there. The difference between
the states go largely to that. But the Clintons
had a strong reservoir of support in New Hampshire
and that was the first important thing. Second
important thing was that there were a lot
of woman voters in New Hampshire had, for
a variety of reasons, drifted away from Hillary
Clinton and drifted largely not into Obama's
column but into the undecided column. So Mark
Penn's theory was that Hillary Clinton needed
to get those, needed to reactivate those women
voters who were inclined towards her but had
been kind of pulled either into; in some cases
they were saying they were pro Obama but in
most cases they were down in the undecided
column. She had to do something and somehow
that had to happen. She needed to bring those
people back home. You know, everybody remembers,
of course, her moment of emotional vulnerability
in New Hampshire. I think that in fact a big
factor and I also think the people of New
Hampshire, if you have spent any time there
as I have, there was a very strong sense of
people in New Hampshire who were very sophisticated
about politics. And the notion that the media
narrative, which was true, which was that
if Obama had of won New Hampshire, the race
would basically have been over. I think there
was a backlash to that among a lot of voters
in New Hampshire, who didn't want the race
to end and didn't want to be part of the coronation
of a candidate who would have been so untested
at that point. To give Barack Obama - given
his relatively newer resume, his relatively
brief time on the national stage; to allow
him to take the Democratic nomination having
only had to succeed in one caucus and one
primary, I think struck people in a very conscious
way as being a problem. If you look at the
polls from New Hampshire, one of the things
you will notice is that - and people say,
"The polls are so wrong, the polls are so
wrong"; they weren't really that wrong. And
what the polls showed going into election
day, was that Obama had a lead, Hillary had
- I won't be able to quote the numbers for
you but Obama had 'x' percent, Hillary had
'y' percent, and there was a 'z' percent undecided.
Obama basically hit his number; what didn't
happen on election day was that he didn't
also get any undecided voters. So what you
saw was something you never see in politics,
which is essentially close to 100% of the
undecided voters went for Hillary Clinton
and so the polls actually had gotten, I think
actually got it right in New Hampshire. What
people got wrong was applying the normal predictive
models to how undecided would break, because
no model ever predicts that a 100% of undecideds
will all go in one direction. But the combination
of Hillary's moment of vulnerability, Obama's
moment of nastiness, if you will, at least
ice coldness on the stage when he said you're
like blowing off Hillary, both contributing
to the same thing which made her seem a much
more sympathetic and appealing figure, especially
to women voters, and this perception that
the people of New Hampshire didn't want to
be the place where the race ended. I think
those were all important factors. And I'd
say on the margin, there was some number of
independent voters in New Hampshire who, seeing
what they thought was an Obama landslide,
decided in a strategic voting way that they'd
rather vote for McCain. And it's an open primary
and independents can vote in either one of
the races. There were a fair number of New
Hampshirens, I can say empirically, and I
think the data actually shows this, that were
actually torn and who actually - their favorite
two candidates were Obama and McCain and they
were very centrist kind of liberal Republicans
- liberal Conservatives, or very conservative
Liberals, if you will, who on the day of the
election thought that my votes not going to
count in the Democratic primary, why not go
the Republican primary and vote for McCain
where it actually will count because that
race was seen as very tight between him and
Mitt Romney so some combination of those factors,
I think tell the story there.
>> It's a good answer and you did answer my
specific question but in particular I was
referring to the exit polls on the day of
the election which also showed that Obama
was winning.
John Heilemann: Now, the exit polls were accurate
in that case.
>> That Obama was going to win?
John Heilemann: No, the exit polls didn't
show that.
>> That's not my memory from the day of the
election.
John Heilemann: You know, I'd be very surprised
if you actually saw exit polls on that day
but the exit polls told the campaign something,
that the actual network exit polls that came
in were actually on the money as to why Obama's
campaign was able to go and tell him he was
going to lose long before the results were
actually finalized. I'll take one more if
you -
>> Last one.
John Heilemann: He's eager.
>> Sorry I'm so late. So I really tried to
understand Obama from his early biography
and [inaudible], but it's just very confusing.
One thing - two questions about Obama. One
is there's this idea that he read "Team of
Rivals" and he sort of thinks of himself as
Lincoln in the sense that he'd come into this,
some sort of catastrophe in the country, and
having to... maybe that's part of the reason
for bringing Hillary and I wonder what you
thought about that. The other question is
something that's even somewhat troubling,
is the fact that you know there was a pretty
well researched book called "The Case Against
Barack Obama" that talked about his history
in Chicago, his associations with a corrupt
machine there, you know, very supportive of
BOGO in 2006, his association with radicals,
criminals, and you know he was right in all
of that. So I wonder how does one make sense
of that, you know?
John Heilemann: Thank you. Well, uh...I think
that the answer to the second question will
be a little too tendentious for us to get
into right now. But I have read the book you
are talking about although I have a feeling
that it's written with some [inaudible] of
ideological predispositions that don't make
it quite straight journalism given the title.
The answer to the first question is yeah.
I mean, I think that Obama thinks that the
amount of crises that he faced when he came
in were on a historic level. He, like Hillary
Clinton, a lot of Presidential aspirants,
really like "Team of Rivals". They think it's
a really great book. Hillary Clinton tried
to institute a team of rivals on her campaign.
It doesn't work very well on campaigns it
turns out especially if you're not willing
to mediate between the war and factions and
then make clear decisions on the basis of
on this letter, we fight. Her theory was if
you let her fight, the best ideas will come
to the top. She didn't seem to realize that
when the best ideas came to the top, she needed
to then endorse one of them and choose that
as a course of action; she seemed to just
let people kind of fight endlessly. There's
no doubt that Obama had read the book and
there's also no doubt that he admires Lincoln
a lot. But you know, I - I mean, Hillary Clinton
was his rival in the Democratic nomination
fight, but I'm being maybe a little bit too
literal about the title of the book, but if
you look around, I think people naturally
kind of fastened on to that when he put her
in the Cabinet. I don't think he really thought
of her that way, in a funny way. I mean, he
obviously did know that he had fought this
race against her and knew that she had been
his rival but I think he wanted to send-in
choosing her, he thought she would do a good
job and he wanted to send a message to the
world about his "bigness", you know, as a
person who was able to move past the campaign
and pull and put someone in the job that he
thought would do the best in that job, and
that not only did he want that substantively,
but he wanted to be seen as someone who would
do that. You know, if you look at the makeup
of his cabinet in general, there's not a lot
of rivalry there. I mean, there are a lot
of people who Obama was very friendly with
or very close to in the past. People like
Arnie Duncan, the Education Secretary, who
he had a great relationship with. In the White
House, the same two of the three people that
Obama actually listens to, who he'd listened
to during the campaign and continues to listen
to, Robert Gibbs and David Axelrod are still
there. He swapped out David Plouffe for Rahm
Emanuel but again it's a very tight circle
of people within the White House who Obama
actually cares about their opinions. And you
know in the context of foreign policy, you
know again this a hard thing again for many
of Obama's more progressive backers to swallow
but I think you know there was consistency.
Hillary Clinton, Bob Gates, Jim Jones; all
pretty hawkish for Democrats. I mean, in Gates's
case, not really a Democratic. People who
were much to the right of where I think a
lot of progressive voters were in terms of
foreign policy, but that's not a team of rivals,
that's a team of people who believe what Barack
Obama seems to believe about foreign policy.
Again, I say many progressives don't, we don't
want to believe that but I think everything
that's happened over the course of the first
year, particularly surrounding the decisions
in Afghanistan, suggest that those people
were put in the office because they had the
same orientation towards national security
that Obama actually has. I mean, I'll conclude
by saying it is, I think, one of the biggest
problems for Obama, is the Rorschach Blot,
blankness of his campaign and the amount of
projection that people put on him and believe
things that he never was, and I think one
of things most, where it's most striking,
is in this area; because I think foreign policy
in the end may be the thing that will be determinative
in the 2012 elections. Around the time in
2011, he has to decide whether or not to withdraw
troops from Afghanistan as he said he was
going to. You know, a lot of people on the
left heard Obama's speech about the Iraq War
in 2002 and thought he said he was against
the Iraq War and that he was an anti-war person,
and what he said was, "I'm not against all
wars, I'm against dumb wars", and I think
it's a salutary and important thing for people
who, to listen to both parts of that sentence.
Again, I take no position on the subject but
this is not a guy who is a pacifist, and I
think his appointments in foreign policy demonstrate
that's pretty clearly the case. So anyway,
thank you very much, you guys, for coming.
[applause]